uh so you buy what those guys are
selling
oh uh well we just heard it from the
experts right here and um
i mean i i
i think just from my perspective of
being you know somewhat in content and
in distribution too um as youtube as a
distribution platform
um i mean i think one of the things
we're seeing is there's just a lot of
change right now happening in the
traditional
tv landscape um you know if we look at
18 to 24 year olds the amount of tv
viewing has decreased
by over 25 percent over the last five
years actually sorry 40 over the last
five years it's 25 for a slightly older
demo right
so
i mean i think if you um you know i
think as a result of some of these
changing demographics and these changing
trends uh the traditional media
companies in the distribution are
looking and thinking like well you know
how do we prepare for this changing
landscape right so i'd say that maybe a
tepid yes
from your perspective well i it's
i mean i think we'll you know everyone
is asking and everyone's learning
um and so
i think the other thing too is is that
there's much more focus on going direct
to consumer um and you know netflix has
definitely shown that amazon's going
direct to consumer right and so the
question is when you're a content
provider
are there benefits of partnering with a
distribution platform and then being
able to go more direct to consumers so i
think you know we'll see over time um
but there'll be some opportunities and
challenges all right we heard from reed
hastings last night we obviously heard
from from jeff and randall this morning
man these guys are big companies they
got big budgets
where does youtube fit into this it
almost seems a little bit uh
uh
unexpected but perhaps the google
product is somehow not at the scale of
these other other companies now i know
you're going to give me 10 stats why
that's wrong yeah um yes but but
nonetheless there seems to be a lot of
big players doing a lot of big things so
what is youtube's role could you could
you do it in a tweet could you tell us
in a tweet sure um
well i think our goal is to be
the next generation
platform for media companies and to do
that in an ad supported and subscription
way and when you're an ad supported
platform and you serve a global market
um like our focus is really reach right
so we serve over a billion users
that come to our site every month and so
if you have something and you want to
have that content become famous you want
that content to have impact like youtube
is a great place to go right um i think
again for the user side if you actually
want to go and learn about anything see
the most
amount of content youtube is going to be
the place to go okay so uh in terms of
developing your own content netflix as
reid was telling us last night they're
putting in 10
to 20 he's targeting 10 million today
perhaps 20 million dollars an hour
of premium content
uh google and youtube have taken a few
baby steps in that regard are you
willing to truly go in the way that
amazon is and that netflix is and so
many other creators are
well i think our models are different
for a few reasons which is that
um i mean netflix either licenses
content or they produce content we're a
platform that enables other companies to
create content or to have that content
distributed um so in a sense like as our
platform model
it doesn't and being ad supported um
also impacts the type of content that we
can do it doesn't make sense for us to
do it
in the same way that netscape and that
uh that's good yeah that's a little
older but okay um
netflix netflix and amazon are doing
right but
but um
you know we started youtube red with
running so you are that's my next
question yeah so we've had youtube red
for about a year how's it going and so
far it's been good can you give us some
numbers on that uh no not yet i'm sorry
how do you feel about it
we feel i'll say optimistic about it and
so youtube right just for um for
everyone who uh in case you don't know
about it it's a uh it's a full music
subscription service in addition to that
we have the youtube stars that develop
content for
um they a lot of times youtube stars
will have big followings on youtube our
largest star pewdiepie has over 45
million subscribers and so we're taking
those top stars and then we're saying
well how do you create uh content and
take it to the next level and so that's
where we felt like we could really
differentiate because you know if we're
to go into the market and compete with
netflix and compete with amazon and do
that in the same way
like that's a that's a competitive
market i don't think we've ever seen as
much content being produced um as is
being so you guys have made the decision
we're just not even gonna go there we're
gonna they're going sort of basically
top down in terms of budgets and
spending you're kind of going bottom up
finding the people who kind of have
their organic audiences and putting them
in better environments well i think
we're focused on the youtube experience
and the youtube audience that we have
there uh and making sure that we are
working with the youtube stars to take
that content to the next level and so
far the reception has been really
positive um and to be clear like the
youtube stars have real followings um so
variety for example did a study and they
looked at american teens and they said
among american teens who are your
biggest stars and
eight of the top 10 were youtubers and
so these are real personalities with
very loyal followings and so really it
made sense for us to work with those
stars as opposed to going out and saying
okay let's do something completely out
of the youtube ecosystem let's do
something focus on the youtube ecosystem
i think you build your subscription
service so subscription services have
this benefit right as you have more and
more users you can develop more and more
content
um and so you can expand that and that's
what reid hastings would say too yeah
and i think they've done a great job of
proving that and so
uh you know for us we need to start
where there's value
for our users which is taking the
youtube stars growing them to the next
level and then having a really amazing
youtube service so
youtube we have um
you know from a music perspective we
just have a lot of really
we have a really large corpus if you're
interested in a specific type of music
you can get that on youtube so we tried
to look at what our strengths were and
then have our subscription service be
focused on that right and what does it
cost per month 9.99 are you giving
anyone here a discount
no we're not sorry all right we'll do
that next year but i recommend that you
try you also get youtube ads free um
which has been and everything is
available offline
and background so it's been i mean our
users are really are really enjoying
okay let's talk about advertising you
obviously had a big part of acquiring
youtube acquiring doubleclick thereafter
yeah uh the advertising uh spaces
changed so much uh certainly since those
deals so what does the advertiser of
2017
want
uh
and how is google giving that and
specifically youtube giving it to the
advertiser yeah
i think advertisers usually fall into
two buckets they're either a direct
response advertiser
meaning they want to sell a specific
good and they want to measure the
click-through and the performance um
they have an online site like
amazon you know they advertise people
click they buy they can measure that
performance
then you might say you have an
advertiser that is
brand oriented so
like gap right people go into their
stores they purchase products they have
positive affinity with the product and
youtube is within google's portfolio
which has traditionally been much more
direct response is really um is really
the largest brand uh property within the
google right can you give us a general
sense of what it costs for a brand to
advertise on youtube
um well uh you know we run it on an
auction basis and so um our advertisers
um so advertising has sold cpm
meaning it sold per thousand impressions
and um
so it will vary
is it changing at all or is it pretty
static right now
i mean i think it's it's uh you know and
it also varies i don't want to give a
specific number because when you look at
advertising you look at that for the
specific audience that you're trying to
reach but then you also look at like is
it men 18 to 24
is it women
in vietnam and actually so one of the
amazing things is we just have really
really broad reach across the globe and
um or do you want to run a global
campaign there was an interesting story
in propublica about uh the merger of
offline and online data uh
for google users
uh
i gotta tell you it didn't make me feel
very good
um
why should we and this was sort of one
of the premise premises of the
doubleclick merger was that merger would
not
happen right that you would not be able
to identify me online and my behavior
offline so why should i trust google
with my activity given that that change
has happened
well google at the end of the day is a
consumer based company right so
we are based upon
users coming to google doing searches
because they believe they're going to
get the best services because they trust
the company
and youtube is the same way
and
so at the end of the day we're
incentivized to do everything
that's right for the user and if i were
to summarize google's philosophy in
um
in two words it would be focused on the
user i guess it's more than two it's
like four words but but focus on the
user is so core and i really think
that's a distinguishing factor um and so
when we think about everything when we
think about advertising we talk about
like you know user performance think
about trueview trueview is an ad format
where we're saying users should come and
they should choose to see the ads right
and and the ad should be good enough
that a user would want to see it and and
the amazing thing about trueview
i'm not sure i would have believed this
um until it actually happened but like
users do want to see ads um and they the
advertisers are now creating content
that looks much more or they're creating
ads that look much more like content
right so maybe the reality is that
people just don't care about privacy in
the way they used to
well i don't want to say that i mean i
think everybody cares about privacy but
at the end of the day you have to
look back and make sure a that you have
control um that you have options you
have the ability to choose what's the
right thing for you right and that the
ascendant the incentives are aligned
right okay so um moving on to um
some of the issues particular to youtube
has been a long-running battle between
copyright holders and youtube about
uh content being used um
you've made a number of changes to to
correct that but it's still a big
complaint out there and um
how do you see that evolving and and uh
do you have any more specific plans to
address particularly as it comes to
music that's posted on youtube
yeah well um i mean we have a
system called content id
which is a technology that we have
invested 60 million dollars in
and content id enables right holders to
be able to give us their content and for
us to be able to identify their content
and then they choose they either will
say
take down my content if it's uploaded to
youtube or they will say leave it up um
and let me make money from it and
monetize it with ads or leave it up and
not monetize it with ads right and why
is the burden of proof though still on
the content holder google is the second
richest company on earth
uh well what burden of which proof
burden of proof on the content holder to
demonstrate that the uh contents being
uh
appropriated i mean content rights are
really
um actually knowing who owns the content
right jeff can tell you the same thing
yeah i mean i think if you talk to
anyone who's a lawyer right like we have
lawyers they clear the content so to ask
a platform to be
to be able um to
um actually do all of that work i think
is is really unrealistic and that's why
we have the dmca um is so that we can
have platforms those platforms enable
innovation and then the content owners
will tell us this is my content um we
will if if it's identified on the
platform then we can take it down but is
that simply calling something a platform
does that give you give
basically free clearance to do as one
sees i mean facebook has some of these
similar problems too so
is is just calling something a platform
good enough uh as we move into 2017.
well so i think it's not just a platform
like we have a platform we have the
technology
um we have lots of uh copyright owners
who use that would paid out two billion
dollars so this is like a real business
if you're a content owner
and you're making additional revenue
from that
it's really valuable okay facebook's had
some problems
uh great story in the wall street
journal about how they were miscounting
some pre-ad roles i believe
did you see that did you know about that
how about i didn't know about until i
read about it but how about
read about it how about is facebook will
you tell us that how how bad is facebook
at doing this stuff um
well i'm not sure i can i can comment
about facebook specifically um but what
i i can say is uh i mean look i i've
been i worked in advertising for i've
worked in everton's for over a decade
before i got to youtube um i led
google's advertising products and you
know i'll just say when we first started
like we would just be like okay here's
your click-through on an ad and people
were like yay i can actually see my
clicks i can see where they came from
like if you read the kennel letter book
um google like he starts with a chapter
of where traditional media comes and
sees google and says oh my gosh like
google's actually going to give away the
magic by by
um or the traditional media companies
say that because google's going to give
all this insight into the metrics and so
we provide these very basic metrics and
then over the 10 years that i was
running our ad systems like we could
never provide enough metrics they were
always like okay we need like 10 more we
need 10 more we need 10 more and we need
10 more right and so i think you know
metrics so what's the single most
important metric now
knowing that all this information is out
there that the advertiser wants today
from youtube because you have to put
pick one okay so we we provide okay we
provide lots and lots of metrics but if
you're an advertiser at the end of the
day what you're gonna go back and you're
gonna look at is you're gonna look and
see did this actually provide positive
roi for me right so i spent a thousand
dollars i made two thousand dollars so
regardless of the metrics that we
provide they're going to see that and
we're going to provide metrics that are
going to now that i have my brand or
like i increased awareness right now
that i have the offline online world's
merged i can probably tell that you went
to
xyz store to spend money on an ad you
saw right so that's that's a value
proposition for an advertiser
well i'm not sure you will know
specifically that
um but but but uh you know marketers for
a long time have been doing in-store
sales right and looking to say oh we
marketed in this region and we got more
sales in this area
they're also third parties so you know
so we provide metrics but then they're
third parties so there's um and their
mrc is a is an accreditation of those
metrics there's comscore there's nielsen
so there are many many ways that those
metrics but metrics look i think you
know there's this old adage about
advertising um that came from
a department store
ceo who said i spend
money on advertising and half of it is
valuable um i just don't know which
house okay so that's the that's the
traditional way that the google has
bumped that up it's like 55
now i think it's a lot more than 55.
what number would you put on it
um oh i think you know 100 like you know
what's what you know like these click
you know these are uh the clicks that i
got you have a good understanding of the
traffic that was driven to your side so
i think there's a lot of um i mean i
really think that advertising had in the
last 10 years has really undergone a
renaissance of being able to give a lot
more metrics and you know again we can
talk about that um here but you know you
look at these small business owners that
actually now can reach audiences and can
have a business that they never had
before it makes a huge difference in our
economy okay we have just a couple
minutes for questions for susan wojcicki
um
please
you could uh say who you are too
absolutely uh hi i'm amy jackson from
glassdoor
so gender pay quality is still um just
the nut that can't be cracked uh it
seems so at youtube how do you tackle
this how do you pay equally um and and
foster that in your workforce yeah
yeah so um i mean i think gender pay
equality is super important and i know
um
uh companies across the board in tech
are have spent time looking at that um i
mean i think we
um we certainly strive to do that um in
every way possible um and you know i
think the way that i personally do that
is you know when we're when we're doing
paid you know our team our hr teams they
go through um equity in general to make
sure that it's fair for everybody right
so you have um a set of people at a
certain level they have similar job
titles how do you make sure that there
is you know a narrow band um among those
those individuals
though right if you have a group of
uh people at the top who don't know who
performs well doesn't that uh sort of
well those companies give performance
ratings so i think you can say well look
we have people who are level x they
perform at level y you know and like our
hr teams go through that and they make
sure that um they're you know if there's
a discrepancy it can be explained um and
in general making sure that there's good
and and um you know there's good
uh you know that the people the same
level with the same performance are paid
in the same band and i think that is
it's not just a gender issue it's a it's
across the board for all types of
backgrounds all types of areas um you
know and i'll just say i've actually
done it i mean there was one evening i
spent the entire evening going through
this for my entire team and it's really
complicated do you look at one year comp
do you look at four-year comp what
happens when you have somebody who is in
um say zurich where there's a different
you know cost of living so our teams
work incredibly hard we're very metrics
driven um to make sure that that
that we have equal pay okay maybe one
last question
uh there please sir
um there's been a lot of talk about
youtube unplugged which is a live tv
service that you're working on do you
have a sense of how much it will cost
and any partners that you'll have in it
yeah so um so though that that news
coverage has is a rumor um
and um i will say that we work with all
of the broadcasters um and all the
traditional media companies we love to
host the content on youtube um we work
with them for promotion to get that
content um distributed for them
and um so
that that's uh that's where we are right
now so i guess if i'm going to interpret
you if i may sure perhaps wrong it
sounds like it's all about the
negotiation and the right price so
that's how i interpret that do you want
to add to that
or correct me it's a rumor okay it's a
rumor but thank you all right
last thought uh what is youtube uh a
year from now is it is it significantly
different or not
well i mean i think we just live in this
really amazing time i mean tv is you
know when i grew up like tv was like the
one and only thing you know that was so
important for delivering entertainment
and with
um
you know and in this we live in a day
and age where
um video distribution
um a it's a it's it's so broadly
available there's so many different
creators of content so so many people
can create content that never created
content beforehand and so really like
our goal is to be a platform for those
next generation media companies and if
you look at the content that's being
created
a lot of times it's really different
from what we saw
on tv so i think you know tv has a lot
of great areas but the how-to content
the music content
science content and so you know we're
really excited about growing our
ecosystem growing all of the creators
that are on youtube
and
um and being available broadly
across the globe and
growing i mean right now we we say we
have a billion users and we'd love to be
available to all all connected users um
across the globe okay so i think that
means a lot more pewdiepie videos are in
our future for better or worse i think
they'll be pewdiepie
and more okay pewdiepie pewdiepie and
more that's right all right thank you
thank you
you